Okay.
It's been a little while since I did this
and people have been emailing, so let's do
it.
Put down your phone, grab a book and read
something.
Okay.
I'm going to give you three book recommendations
today.
You can of course find all of my recommendations@davidpakman.com
slash recommendations and if you use the links
there to buy any of these books or any of
the books that are already on there, we get
a little bit of a slice, a slice of your Amazon
transaction.
Okay.
I've got two nonfiction books for you and
then a fiction book, first nonfiction book.
Just read this last week very, very quick
read.
Very interesting.
The book is thinking in bets by Annie Duke.
Annie Duke is both a poker player and a sort
of business consultant.
And thinking in bets is a very interesting
book for me as someone in politics because
we deal very often with beliefs and so often
conversations in politics are this is true
or that's not true.
And in reality, even when we say those things,
typically what we're doing is we're, we're
assessing the probability that something is
true.
We have some level of confidence that something
is true that is greater than zero but less
than 100 and what Annie Duke very interestingly
does and in a way that with a lot of interesting
stories and anecdotes and examples is she
says we would benefit from thinking in bets
when we think about our views and decisions
that we are making.
So much like I said in the last segment, if
you told me I need to make a bet about is
Michael Bloomberg or Amy Klobuchar more likely
to be the nominee, there's a certain amount
money that I'd be willing to bet based on
what the return would be.
And this is where the idea of, you know, even
money, odds and bedding comes from when you
have odds, you might bet on something that
is very unlikely if the reward feels in proportion
to how unlikely it is.
So the book talks a lot about, you know, when
we say, uh, clearly the, um, uh, clearly the,
the, uh, ice caps melting are a sign of climate
change.
We are really dealing in an assessment of
how likely we believe that to be.
And when you say to me, are you 100% sure
about this, that or the other thing about
climate change?
No, not a hundred percent sure, but I'm sure
enough that I wouldn't bet against it.
And that is exactly the framework that Annie
Duke talks about and says in conversation
we would also be much more open to other ideas
if the conversations are less about, I believe
a you believe the opposite of a and more about,
well I believe this would 70% probability,
you seem to believe it only with 40% probability.
Let's figure out where the difference comes
in and let's figure out what level of risk
or what level of loss we are willing to accept
very important political applications to the
idea of thinking in bets.
So that's thinking in bets by Annie Duke,
completely different type of book.
I'm a about three quarters of the way through
this one.
How to lie with maps by Mark Mon Manye I recommended
to you, um, I think it's called, how to lie
with statistics some years ago by I believe
the author's last name is Hough.
And that is a classic old book.
I think it might even be from the, it might
be the fifties might be the 70s it is a great
book that tells you how we should apply a
skeptical eye to statistics in scientific
studies, in advertising, in commercials, in
news reports.
This is the more academic equivalent of that
specifically with maps and graphical representations
of data.
So the book very clearly explains with examples
how you can use a visual representations of
data and maps to further your political propaganda
goals.
How at the local level maps can be used, you
know, to try to get the zoning board to approve
your swimming pool or whatever the case may
be.
Maybe less relevant globally, but still important
to understand when it comes to climate.
Really important ways that maps can be used
to distort when it comes to, as many of you
know, when you have a globe, when you have
a spherical earth and you try to map that
earth onto a piece of paper onto something
flat, you have to somehow account for the
fact that you're taking a sphere and flattening
it out.
And the ways in which one chooses to do that
have very different implications about political
power, about geography and so many different
things.
All of that and things that I just haven't
gotten to yet cause I'm only three quarters
of the way through.
The book is discussed in this book, how to
lie with naps by Mark Mon money a check it
out.
Very good.
One highly recommended.
All right.
Lastly today here is a fiction recommendation.
There are people in my audience who love the
author Neil Stevenson.
I've read a lot of his work.
He wrote snow crash, which is a book emblematic
of the cyberpunk genre.
He wrote Zodiac, a sort of eco thriller that
takes place in Boston.
He's written a lot of really, really great
books.
I've had um, his book Anthem for a while and
have not yet read it because I just couldn't
feel it.
It didn't feel ready to make like the 900
or thousand page commitment.
I have started reading his book fall and I
planned to read.
This one is like 900 pages.
I planned to read just the first couple of
hundred pages and then put it down.
I'm about 600 pages in, and the book is fantastic.
It is a journey through a long period of time.
It is a story about, in a sense, the digitizing
of our human consciousness.
The characters are extraordinarily interesting.
The writing as always by Neil Stevenson is
extraordinary.
It is a commitment.
I'm about 600 pages in this is fall or Dodge
in hell.
That's the, the full title of the book.
Neil Stevenson, if you've read anything by
him, I recommend this.
If you liked any of the other things we've
read by him.
If you've never read anything by Neil Stevenson,
I dunno that I start with fall, I'd probably
start with snow crash or Zodiac, um, or Seveneves.
But I could not recommend this more highly.
It is a journey.
It is a journey through time and space, the
likes of which only Neil Stevenson can weave
together.
So there's three recommendations for you.
Find all of these and more at David pakman.com/recommendations.